naomi osaka withdrew from the french
open
over the weekend lengthy statement
posted on social media very simple chain
of events
she chose not to participate in a
post-match press conference she was
fined fifteen thousand dollars and
threatened in a collective statement by
all four of the grand slam tournaments
that you may be
defaulted
from the tournament if you continue so
she just said fine i'm out see you later
i withdraw
bye bye find someone else to play tennis
instead of me if you're gonna do this to
me and look
it's it's sparked
a political debate
did it really it got into a political
debate
yeah are you being sarcastic
everything becomes a political debate
nowadays people who have never heard of
naomi osaka are triggered by the fact
that she chose not to participate in a
post-mass press conference that they
wouldn't have even known that she was
participating in but how dare you stand
up to authority how dare you exercise
your individuality how dare you question
the way things are so look i support
what she did
i don't care what the reason is is it
mental health is it just i don't feel
like doing it i don't care because chris
that's what prompted me to write a
broader item at pft and it harkened back
to the days of marshawn lynch and his
desire to not participate in press
conferences i think
sports especially the nfl has evolved to
the point where it no longer needs to
parade out the players and the coaches
to be available for the media because
that's the only way we get the media to
write stories about us this is a vestige
of the days when the nfl was desperate
for attention so you make people
available to talk and you hope that you
can get
the reporters who cover these events to
write stories in their newspapers about
your team we're going to write the
stories whether they talk or not we're
going to talk about the teams whether
the individuals involved talk or not and
i really do think the time has come to
ask the simple question nfl and
elsewhere but particularly in the nfl
since we're a football show does it make
sense
to force guys to do something they don't
want to do when that something is
completely independent of why they play
football i i i get it listen it's a it's
a touchy subject certainly i i don't
necessarily agree with you on all those
points though that that's where you know
again
yes i mean do we need it no i mean we're
gonna have a show no matter what but the
show's better when patrick mahomes does
talk and has a clip and we talk there's
more things to talk about within the
sport it helps the sport that way so
that's where i look at it a little
differently now like football is a team
sport maybe you can get away with it a
little bit more by not having a certain
guy available and doing all those type
of things tennis course is an individual
sport so i do think maybe it's even more
important for somebody like naomi osaka
maybe to be involved in something like
that i know she obviously has an issue
and and marshawn liscio
lynch had an issue as well to a degree
but i i it's a tough one just in the
also in the the sense of
you know
it it is part of the sport it's part of
the broader business
is it though yeah it is
i i think for the nfl particularly we've
gotten to a point where it doesn't have
to be mandatory and chris this isn't a
binary
you know all or nothing type of a
situation
if you drop the mandate that players be
available they're still going to do it
most of them she said she wouldn't she
wasn't going to do it marshawn lynch
wouldn't do it i mean he wouldn't has
there been another guy since marshawn
lynch who has who has gone to the
lengths because there's an easy loophole
a very easy loophole and i went round
and round with the nfl with this at the
time because it was nonsensical to me
okay you don't show up you get fined you
show up and you say in response to every
question
no matter how well formulated or
brilliant the question may be or
incisive or or designed to help promote
the nfl if the response to every
question is i'm just here so i don't get
fined what's the point what's the point
it's like it's like you know like
it's just a stupid punishment you must
be there we don't tell you what you have
to say you can say
i'm just here so i don't get fined or
you can just give a bunch of
non-responsive answers like marshawn
launch did another time he just said
thank you every question thank you that
was his response so why make him do that
when at the end of the day you can't
because it because because it's
something that he just doesn't want to
do the league's set up a way it has
nothing to do with him it was just he
didn't want to do it as soon as it was
like as soon as there was an
advertisement that was willing to pay
him a bunch of money with the camera
i'll talk all i want do it okay but
that's part of the business there's a
team there's a company paying
millions and millions and millions of
dollars to
uh to to be the team that sponsors the
seattle seahawks or whoever it may be
and within that
they want those most famous players on
that team to be talking in front of
their logos and things like that because
those most famous of players like
marshawn lynch or russell wilson or
whatever those guys those get the people
that stand all that okay but that's part
of the business i don't know but it's
one guy in 10 years okay said i'm not
doing it all right that's my point yeah
why do we have to make it mandatory
russell wilson's still going to talk dk
metcalf still going to talk tyler
lockett's still going to talk these guys
are still going to talk
because they could show up and say i got
nothing to say to you today
they can only find you if you don't show
up my point is this if guys really are
committed to not talking they have an
easy loophole that is hiding in plain
sight just show up and stand there yeah
and say okay yes
even if it's not a yes no question
that's fine what do you think of today's
game yeah yes yes and that's acceptable
and you don't get in trouble right so my
point is my point is
let's take a step back instead of having
an authoritarian attitude toward these
athletes and thou shalt do what we want
you to do and if you don't we're gonna
rub your face in your own crap which is
the attitude that i think a lot of
people have yeah you do what you're told
and you shut up and you sit down and you
say please and thank you and you be
grateful you have a job where you're
making all this money that attitude's
got to end that's an unhealthy attitude
because the players will choose to do it
they're going to choose to talk a lot of
them want to talk and a lot of them
understand if i show up and i do a good
job i get sponsors i i get a job
uh call them football games when i
retire so my point is this to have this
hard and fast rule
that that is imposed with chronic
draconian efficiency sorry
what's the point of it when what you're
dealing with is one person
out of 10 000
that's going to be the one that says i
don't want to do it that that and it
just it's just a bad look well to be so
heavy-handed when why don't we just why
wouldn't how about an experiment how
about an experiment it doesn't have to
be permanent
one year
it's completely vulnerable oh you're
good mike you're crazy
you're gonna have so many players after
losses on a sunday go i don't want to
talk to the media i'm not too i'm you're
going to have you're going to you're
going you're crazy you're giving the
players too much credit they're going to
be way more the big ones that are going
to go chris i don't want to talk i don't
want to say they can still show up and
say i don't want to talk okay they can
still show up and give non-answers they
can still show up and storm out like cam
newton did after super bowl 15. fine my
point is i'm willing i'm willing and
people get mad at me oh you're in the
media business you're you're you're
going against the interest of the media
we need to have these people talk
we we don't need to treat them like
anything other than humans who have free
will and free decisions but if you give
them
better if they choose to talk if you
give them the right to talk mike you're
going to have a lot more not talk than
talk i can just tell you i'm willing to
do it for a year all right why i'm not i
want make their butts get in front of
there and talk it's part of the business
i don't care naomi osaka even to that
she's the most famous female player in
the sport right now sorry i don't care
about tennis okay but i'm just saying
that's what but even within the football
team
we go to the super bowl every year right
this past year because of the pandemic
we have to turn people away
they will talk because there has been
for the most part mike they're not
people that are the stars of the show
right now they're guys that are being
paid and other things to do it we turn
away
okay
but my point is they all show up we're
in a position where we have the luxury
of turning people away whether or not
they be has beens
we have the luxury of saying no we have
to say no because we have the stars of
the game they are there they choose to
talk my point is
the people aren't talking
because they're
threatened with sanctions if they don't
talk they'll talk i mean do you think if
patrick mahomes really don't want to
talk he's going to talk
now look what happens in some of these
cities there will be situations where
players aren't complying with the media
obligations and it just kind of happens
and no one has the the will to be the
one who call it battles to the league
office that happens from time to time
but but you know what the sport still
survives people are still going to
choose to talk and i'm only saying the
players the coaches should be required
to talk and i think the game officials
frankly should be retire required to
talk after every game but i i just i
there's just a quality to it
and and we see what we see in every
other situation when a fight like this
breaks out the fans line up behind the
billionaires
against the players i know and uh
i'm not even saying you need to have a
slip that says you've got social anxiety
like ricky williams did remember when he
would do it yeah sure
with his helmet on right with a visor a
dark visor because he had a medical
condition because all these people
swarming around him made him anxious you
should no if you don't want to do it
don't do it because my my point is this
i'm willing to do the experiment for a
year because guys will still
talk we will still have content
and uh yeah maybe there'll be one or two
who don't fine then we write a story
about why so-and-so chose not to talk he
didn't want to come face the music we
could still criticize him for not
talking oh i know oh you didn't come
face-to-face i know we'll survive it
just makes it better when you when they
do it makes the sport better it makes
everything about it better everything
you know it does it makes your website
better i woke up on sunday morning there
was six player quotes on the front page
of pft made it better all for and
they're all from the time in the year
where no one's required to talk well i
know okay so but but but there's still
going to be too many times during the
year where big time players if given
that option will not talk and and listen
mike i understand i'm not willing to do
it and keep a score card i'm trying not
to be insensitive to it because i know
there are people with real problems i
guess we're i have problems with it
sometimes more than others is when
yeah i don't want to do that i have you
know
i don't like it there's too many people
blah blah blah but then they go and
leave and they do other things that
cause attention to themselves or you
know put themselves in a similar
situation where you're like well
obviously you were
bull crapping or lying about your like
whether it was your anxiety or not
wanting to answer or be around those
crowded people because here you are now
you know doing those same type of things
and so that's where i just i guess i
have a little issue with it where i see
that sometimes too
i just think that the people who believe
that that there would be some mass
exodus from the locker room i mean you
still have locker room access if you
were you up to a guy and if you don't
want to talk you don't have to talk i
just i just i think that the
the downside to that
would be far less significant than than
people think i really i really believe
that and uh the problem is no one's
willing to try it they're so concerned
that there will be this
this
widespread universal shunning of
reporters that they're not even willing
to give it a try i just think that it's
worth a try because at the end of the
day it should just be the people who who
want to talk the people who talk from
the end of the season until the start of
the next season when they don't have to
they still talk i mean patrick mahomes
talked up a blue streak all weekend it
was part of his event but guys have
occasions and reasons to talk there will
not be a a vacuum of information and now
in this day and age to chris we got
social media we got plenty of ways for
players to get their message out right
well that's what i'm saying they'll go
home and do their own media but they're
not going to let the media do their job
that's why i don't i'm not cool with
that oh we do our job we just do our job
a different way okay well i don't do our
job okay well listen part of the job in
doing this is this part of playing in
the nfl to me that's it's part of the
job is answering questions from those
people who do
you know
their due diligence and inform the
public and people about the person the
player all the things it's part of the
sickle cyclical pattern of of what goes
on in the nfl in the business so that's
where it's tough and i i i am one i
guess i'm guess i'm old school that way
to where i just don't know
and and look i this is going to piss off
a lot of reporters but why do we think
we're entitled to go into a locker room
after a game to get
controversial quotes from players who
are pissed off because they just lost a
championship or some guy just made some
horrible mistake and he's going to have
50 microphones stuck in his face and be
forced to talk about it when did we
decide that we're the people with the
power to go do that that that's what i
don't understand why should anyone be in
that situation yeah there's this idea
that the quotes are only hang on the
quotes are only compelling if they're
fresh the quotes are only compelling if
you get this guy in his deepest darkest
moment why are we entitled to that
that is is that not a fair question to
ask why are we entitled to delve into
someone's psyche when they're in the
immediate aftermath of one of the worst
moments of their professional lives why
are we entitled to that
because why
i don't i don't really know i mean i'd
have to think about that a little but
for most players that's why they signed
up to be on the opposite side of that oh
i want to be the guy the man don't talk
to them do well talk to them no it's
part of the sport now you got to handle
a little failure and explain it to the
world okay this is why you played the
sports and why you get paid millions of
dollars and get all these other benefits
oh no you have to answer some questions
about how a a game went tough and didn't
go in your way there's worse things in
life i just don't want to hear you think
i don't want to hear you think that
people will stop watching football if
they no longer have raw unvarnished
access to the things that players say
after no probably not i have a
microphone in their face and they're
asked why did you suck today uh
yeah i i don't think it i don't think
it's going to help the sport i'm going
to change a thing oh i'm going to hurt
it it could hurt it we've seen the sport
get hurt already by things that were set
into the mic or you know into the
microphone or not the sportsman hurt by
the things like so yes
guys acting like jerks and doing that is
not going to be a positive thing for the
sport it's not there's no way but but my
point is chris
it's isn't it better to just let the
guys who don't want to talk not talk at
all if that could potentially hurt the
sport let the guys who want to be the
ambassadors be the ambassadors they will
bear the benefit of it with other
earning opportunities with future media
opportunities there will be pl
my point is there's so many guys in the
nfl
i know but i want to hear from the five
best players in the team i don't want to
hear from player 27 on the roster the
seattle seahawks lose there's five guys
i want to hear from i don't really give
a damn about the rest of the guys and
that's the way the rest of the sports
world is too i want to hear from russell
wilson dk metcalf jamal adams all right
after you get past those guys i just
want to go well okay great but i want to
hear from them they're the stars i want
to know where their minds at after the
big loss i do it's part of it it's
entertainment it's part of the what we
do right now i i don't think we can
start like separating it to me
i i think i'm willing to do one year
make it optional i don't think anything
will change all that much
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports